E
KALARI INE, WHERE SHE INGISLATO
REAMBL TO EXPEL
TWO ELTE
JONESROM
THE LEGTUREJO AND
RULES TO PARTICIPATE IN GUN
REFORM PROTES
LEGISLATIV IN RESPONSO D SCHOOL
THEHI THAT STATMAKERSAVLEDLEGIE
E LAWMAKER BRIAN
REPRESENTATIVE RICHIETH
FOING US, SO YOU WERENE
EPUBLICANSHOXPORIA JOHNSON.NDTHR
I STAR SHARING WITH
LEADERSHIP
RIGHT THING. WHAT THESE T
AS COMPLETEL
HOASIS TO
OUR GENERAL ASSELYE
THAT HAVE SERVED BEFOND SERVETN
DID IT CONSTITUTE THEM BEING
EXPELLED? ABSOLUTELY.
OPWAS IT WARRANTED?OTFFICE IS
RIGHT NEX MINE. I
MUIPIONS WITH HIM
THIS WEEK. LET ME KNOWT I
WA ESSENTIALLY
OW WAS GROWINGTTGTIONAL OUTSE HS
EX AND THAT THE METRO CCIL HAD O
UM, BACK TO THE GENERALASSEMBLYS
IMT I
DI THAT ANY OF THEM
GEIN
OU E IT WASD BAS ON THE LETTER F
THE LAW.O REPUBLICA
EXPELWO YOUNG M ANDNOT THE 60 YJ
WHO DID THE SON.HAT THAT'S BECAS
LO THE REST OF THEY? THAT'S THAD
THERE AND MS NSESENTATIVE JOHNSD
THERE SHE WHEN ,
DEO CLEARLY SHOWED HER
STANDING THERE NOTCH
, AND I THINK THAT
MEMBERS TO NOT VOTE FOR HER.
STILL THERE HIN T COLOR OF
THEIR SKIN. I HEM ANDUENTS
THAT VOTED FEYHO. UM I HONORED
NOTHING T WRAT
THAT'S STATING THAT IS JUST
TRYIO TALK. POLITIC
NONSENSE. THHOULD NOTE USSED, SS
GOTTEN SO MUCH ATTENTION. IT'S
JUSTHE PUNISHMEN
SMU TAN. UMKNOW. LAST YEAR, THN
WA INDICTED. ONFEDERAL CHARGESHT
EXPELLED FHA,
REIC LAWMAKERRD WE COVERED TE
TEENAGE GIRLS YEARS BEFORE WHEN
THEY WERE ON HIS WASOT
. UM IF REPUBLICANS ARESOON ABOD
COND WHYLD BURN AND
BURDENEDADA B SG AS TWANTED, WHA
FRESHMAN LAWMAKER
. I N' WHAT
L2018. I
KNOW TT THE CONVERSATIONS KINGSE
REPUBLICARTY THIS EKS
LIFEMEOMEBODYIRSTY
JUST BLALY, DISRUPTINGLOHA A PRT
REPUBLICANTHROTING A EVERYBODY H
OTHER, BUT NOT DID I
PAST. IT WAS BASEDN THIS RIGHTRH
NEEDED TO SET
TWO SEN 12, IT'S THERE INT'WH ET
BLACK ANDGUESS, UH,OTIS IS GETTH
DISTURBED INDIVIDUAL GOI INTE CT
O
ATNRIUM YOU KNOW, JUSTT HORRIFIC
MAOTING. AND SEEMS
LOT OF PEOPLE OUTSIDE THATMAANR
THESE IN PEOPLE KILLED
AT THICHRISTIAN SCHOOL. Y
THAT'S COMPL. UMAT
MEDIA' AND
THAT'SEE
DI WANT TO S MEMBER OF
BODY REPLIR DEMOCRATHA
WAS NOT DEVASTATED BY THIS TOOKT
SW WHEN IT C TOSLATIV, THESE THA
REAND SAYINGFOR GUNO
DND
PROTECT OUR KIDS WERE A
SAME. TTHEPURSUIT BILLS
IN FEBRUARYTHAT,  PHASINGTRODUCE
INDIVIDUS FYESTERDAY, SO IT'S VY
ST AND WE NEED TOT
. ANDKIDS YET THEDON LEGISLATIOD
WHEN IME
PR HAVE BILL
WAS BIN DIDN'T SUBMITY
THEN THETA THAT BUILDS
BEING VOTED ON NO IS JUST
INION TO TH HENOTH. BECAUSE THOE
PLANNEDK IN
OVMATHE OUT TO
THE FALIES AND THE COMMUNITY, IH
SHOULD NEVER END UP HNI
BUT IT'S SOM EVERYERTHL IS WORNG
ANYBODY TRYINGKE
STATEMENT THATS WHAHAS
TRUTH. IT
AMOUNT OF TI, BUT I JUST W
GNON THIS INTHE  OF THE PARKLAF
ASSED RED L
THAT'SN ENCOEDN THEIONAL RA LEGS
AFTER THE VALDEZ SHOIN, BUTYOU'T
L
OR NO? IS THAT SOMETNGLITHINK AT
WOULD NHAT LASTLD YOU BE?
WH WE OU LEAST BE
LAWEPTHAT HAVE BEEN FLAGGED? UH,
GOVERNOR IF GORNNGSLATURE.'M NF
LAW IS SO AND I S
MANY THINGS. UM I THIDING CITEND
WHICH TENNESS HAS STE SOMEBODY
PE GUNS ALR OBOOKS. BUT EVOD
OVEROULD HAVE